The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I apologize to
those of you watching on
OpenCourseWare.
I forgot to turn on
my microphone.
And you missed some incredibly
brilliant things.
But such is life.
Let me go back to where I was,
which was we we're looking at
this code to find the cube
root of a perfect cube.
We saw this last week, and
indeed, you also saw it in
recitation.
I'm not going to belabor it.
I do want to ask you the
question, for what values will
this program terminate?
That is to say the only
input is to x.
For what values of
x is this program
guaranteed to always stop?
Anybody want to volunteer
an answer to that?
Ask a simpler question.
Let's assume that
x is a number.
In fact, let's assume
it's an integer.
Will it terminate for all
positive integers, all
positive values of x?
Yeah.
All negative values?
As far as I can tell.
How about 0?
Yeah.
So in fact, it terminates
for all values of x.
How do I know that?
And that's a key question.
I know that because I've used,
and I mean by used as a mental
tool, something in my head,
the notion of a
decrementing function.
And every time I write a loop,
I think about one of these,
because that explains to
me why the loop is
guaranteed to terminate.
We'll go over here where we have
a bigger board and look
at the properties that
a decrementing
function needs to have.
One, it will map some
set of program
variables to an integer.
Two, when the loop is entered
for the first time or when I
encountered the test of the loop
for the first time, its
value is non-negative.
Three, when its value gets to
be less than or equal to 0,
the loop terminates.
And finally four, it's
decreased each
time through the loop.
So what we see is if it starts
to be a positive value or
non-negative, and it's decreased
every time I execute
the body of a loop, that
eventually, it's got to reach
0 or something less than 0.
And when it does,
the loop stops.
If such a function exists, then
the loop is guaranteed to
always terminate.
Now, of course, one can count up
to a value instead of down.
But there's always a trick we
can use of subtracting to make
it the same.
So what's the decrementing
function for this loop?
How did I know it will
always terminate?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Answer equals
answer plus 1.
I don't think so.
Does that satisfy all
of these properties?
Remember, a function is going
to map some set of program
variables to an integer.
So what are the interesting
program variables here?
Well, there are only
two, ans and x.
Right?
At least, that's
all I can see.
So what would be an interesting
function?
Somebody?
Surely, there's someone who
can figure this out.
Yes?
Or no, you're just scratching
your head.
You fooled me.
I can't see because of the
light, but I'm sure there must
be dozens of hands up if
I could only see them.
Actually, I don't see
any hands up.
This is not so hard, guys.
It's the absolute value of
x minus answer cubed.
So what does this
value start at?
Let's pick a value.
Suppose that x is equal to 8.
What is the initial value of
the decrementing function?
Wow.
Come on.
Let's be a little cooperative,
please.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it's 8, answer
is 0 and absolute
value of x is 8.
PROFESSOR: So it's 8 minus
0, which is equal to 8.
So it satisfies conditions
one and conditions two.
What happens to this value every
time through the loop?
Does x change?
Does answer change?
And how does it change?
It's increasing.
What does answer start at?
It starts at 0, and
it increases.
So I know that answer cubed
will always be positive.
Right?
So I know that every
time through the
loop, it will be 8.
The first time through,
it'll be 8 minus 1
cubed, which is 7.
And then the next time through,
it'll be 8 minus 2
cubed, which is 0.
And then, I exit the loop.
And it's that kind of reasoning
that I used to
convince myself that this
loop terminates.
And every time I write a loop,
and I hope every time you
write a loop, you will think
about what's the reason the
loop is going to terminate.
And you will do it by thinking
about what the decrementing
function is.
People get me on that?
And whoever finally answered
a question surely
deserves to be fed.
I obviously have to bring better
candy to encourage
better responses.
Now, let's go back and look
at the program itself.
Now that we know it stops, and
you can take my word for it
that it actually computes the
correct answer, let's think
about what kind of algorithm
this is.
What's the method?
This is an example of
guess and check.
And it's a particular kind
called exhaustive enumeration.
Each time through the loop, I'm
taking a guess at to what
the value is, and I'm checking
whether it's true.
But I'm enumerating
the guesses in a
very systematic way.
They're not just
random guesses.
I'm enumerating all the
possible answers.
If I get through the entire
space of answers, or possible
answers, and I don't find a
solution, then I know that it
doesn't exist, and it's
not a perfect cube.
So that's why it's called
exhaustive enumeration because
I'm exhausting the space
of possible answers.
Does that makes sense
to everyone?
So let's try it.
Let's try it with say a very
large value of x, because
that's always an issue, of
course, when we do exhaustive
enumeration.
So I'm going to enter
this value.
Is that a perfect cube?
Who thinks it is?
Who can tell me what it is?
What's the cube root of that?
Well, this is a question I did
not expect you to answer.
But it's 1,251.
That'll be in the first quiz,
so make a note of it.
Notice how quickly the
computer did this.
It found the cube
root of quite a
large number very quickly.
And so while one might
initially think that
exhaustive enumeration is a
silly technique because takes
a lot of guesses, for an awful
lot of problems, we can
actually just write a pretty
stupid program that's solves
it by exhaustive enumeration.
We typically refer to such
programs as brute force.
And brute force is often
exactly the right
way to solve a problem.
Why does it work?
Because computers
are really fast.
How fast are computers?
Well, today, a good computer
can execute in a single
processor in the order of 100
million instructions a second.
How fast is that?
And now, we're going to see if
Mitchell has answered the
question I asked in the
way in the class.
How many instructions can a
computer execute between the
time I say something and the
time the people in the back
row hear it?
Mitch thinks it's 400 million
instructions.
I think that's about right.
It's hundreds of millions
at any rate.
It's kind of amazing between the
time I say something and
the time you hear it, hundreds
of millions of instructions.
It's mind boggling
how fast that is.
And that's why we can often use
these kind of solutions.
Next lecture, actually, even
a little bit later in this
lecture, I hope to get to an
example of why that doesn't
really get the job done,
at least not always.
Before I do that, I want
to look at one
more programming construct.
And that's a variant
on the while loop.
So if we think about what the
while loop we were just
looking at did or does, as the
decrementing function told us,
it's looking at all the possible
values of answer
ranging from 0 to the
absolute value of x.
And at each step testing and
doing something, we can
abstract this process using
something called a for loop.
So let's look at this code.
It's essentially exactly
the same algorithm.
I got bored of typing ans
times ans times ans.
So I used a Python notation
for exponentiation, which
you'll see is star, star.
Now, be easier to read
if I get rid of that.
But other than that, the
interesting thing I did was
replace the while
loop by a for.
So you'll see this line of code
there, for ans in range 0
to abs of x plus 1.
What that says is range is a
built-in function of Python
that generates, in this case,
a sequence of integers,
something called a tuple, which
we'll be looking at in a
lecture or so.
But for now, it's pretty simple
to think about what you
get is if you look at the
expression range of x to y,
that gives me a sequence
of values, x, x plus 1
up to y minus 1.
Notice not up to y, but
So it gives me a sequence
of length y--
well, assuming that's 0.
Right?
It doesn't have to be 0.
It can be anything.
It can be another
value as well.
0 in my example.
And then, the for loop executes
it on this value and
the next iteration on this
value, and finally, at the
very end on that value.
So it executes it one iteration
of the loop on each
value in this sequence
of values generated
by the range statement.
And normally, it does
all of them.
However, you'll see I've added
something called a break here,
a command in Python.
And what break says
is exit the loop.
So it exits it prematurely
without executing all of the
values generated by range.
You can nest loops just like
you nest if statements.
And if you do that break,
always executes--
always exits rather the
innermost loop.
So what this does is it's
generates a set
of values to test.
It checks whether or not
it's got the answer.
If it does, it terminates
the loop.
And eventually, you
exit the loop.
And then, it just checks as
before whether or not it found
a correct answer and does
the right thing.
So you'll find, particularly
when you're iterating over
integers, but later we'll see
when you're iterating over a
lot of other kinds of things,
for loops are a very
convenient shorthand.
There's nothing you can't
do with a while loop.
You don't need for loops.
But they do make life easy.
And over the semester, I think
you'll end up writing a lot
more for loops than you
will while loops.
Any questions about this?
If not, I'm going to
move right along.
So this is the moment.
I'm going to move right along.
So we've now got a program that
does something really
silly, really.
It finds cube roots
of perfect cubes.
Well, that's not typically
useful.
Right?
You've even got these $0.50 four
function calculators that
find square roots.
And they don't insist that you
only give it perfect squares.
So now, let's think about how
we would take this kind of
program, and indeed, this kind
of method of writing programs
and use it to find--
for now, we'll look at the
square root of any number, of
any floating point number.
Well, the first question we need
to ask is what do I mean?
That's kind of a subtle
question.
What does it mean to find the
square root of a number?
What does it mean, for
example, to find the
square root of 2?
Well, we know that that was an
endless series of digits
before we can find the
square root of 2.
Right?
It does not have
a nice answer.
So we can't just say we have to
find something that if we
multiply it by itself,
it will equal 2.
Because we can't find
such a thing.
So we've got to think
about a different
notion of what we mean.
Furthermore, even for some
numbers which there is a
square root, it might be a
million decimal places long,
and consequently, really
hard to find.
So we need to think
about a different
kind of concept here.
And it's the concept of an
approximation, finding an
answer that is good enough.
So what should we do here?
How do we think about this?
Typically, what we do when we
think about an approximation
is we define how good
an approximation
we're willing to accept.
So for example, we might want
to say, I want to find a
square root that lies
within epsilon of
the true square root.
So find a y such that y times
y is equal to what?
What does it mean?
How would I express it within
epsilon of the perfect answer?
I don't want to say it's equal
to x, because that may be
impossible or too time
consuming to find.
So really, what I mean is
x plus or minus epsilon.
So that's what I'm asking.
Find one that's close enough.
And that's what the next
piece of code I
want to show you does.
Excuse me.
So I'm starting, just giving it
a value for x, so I don't
have to keep typing one in.
Let's say it's 25.
I'm going to take epsilon
to be 0.01.
So I want it within that
distance of the true answer.
I'm going to keep track of the
number of guesses here, not
because we need it to actually
compute the answer, but
because I want to then discuss
how many iterations of the
loop we're doing.
We're going to start by setting
my first guess at 0.0.
Again, this is going to be
exhaustive enumeration.
Then, I'm going to essentially
encode this as a test of my
while loop while the absolute
value of answer squared minus
x is greater than or equal to
epsilon, and answer is less
than equal to x.
So it's now a more
complicated test.
I've got a Boolean value.
Two things have to be true to
execute the body of the loop.
I'm going to increment answer
by a tiny amount, increment
the number of guesses just so
I can keep track of it.
Maybe I'm going to comment
this out for the first go
around just so we don't see too
many print statements and
keep doing it.
And then when I'm done I'm going
to see whether or not
what I found is indeed a square
root or close enough.
So if we think about why this
loop terminates, why am I
guaranteed that this loop
will terminate?
What's my decrementing
function here?
Somebody?
What's the decrementing
function?
What am I guaranteed to reduce
each time through, and when I
get through, I'm done?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
answer squared minus
x1 times 1.
PROFESSOR: No.
Close, sort of.
But I appreciate
you're trying.
That's worth something
just for the effort.
Somebody else.
Remember, if we look at the
properties it has to have,
it's going to guarantee me that
when it gets to the right
value, I exit the loop, which
suggests it's going to
certainly be part of the
test of the while.
Just look at this piece
over here at the end.
Answer starts at 0.
I keep incrementing it.
Eventually, answer minus x
will hit a value, right?
Eventually, I'll get to
the point that this
condition must be true--
must be false rather.
And then, I exit the loop.
So this piece is not
really the key.
It's this piece that guarantees
me I'm going to get
out eventually.
This piece can get
me out sooner.
It's kind of an optimization,
if you will.
So I'm just going to go until
I find the answer.
Let's see what happens
when I run it.
It tells me that 4.99, et cetera
is close to the square
root of 25.
So there are some things
to note about this.
First, it didn't find 5, 25
happens to be a perfect
square, yet I didn't find it.
Is that OK?
Yeah.
Because that wasn't
what I said.
What I said is find
a y that has these
properties over here.
And I did.
I didn't say find the y that
gets closest to the
square root of x.
I said find one that has
these properties.
Effectively, what this is is a
specification of the problem.
And I've now written a piece
of code that meets the
specification.
It does what I set out to do,
and that's good enough.
Now, let's turn this print
statement back on.
It took almost 1/2 million
guesses to get there.
But it was still blindingly
fast.
So once again, exhaustive
enumeration seems to be OK.
Suppose, however, I choose
a bigger number.
Now, first, let's choose
something that doesn't have a
good answer.
Let's see what it
does for that.
All right.
Pretty good.
Also pretty fast.
Not too many guesses.
But now, let's try this one.
Well, it's going to wait.
It's going to get done, but it's
going to take a little
bit longer than maybe
we want it to take.
Why is it taking so long?
There it is.
It found an answer, which
I think is good.
But as you can see, it
took quite a few
guesses to get there.
So why?
Well, let me first ask
this question.
Can we look at the code and
anticipate how many guesses
it's going to have to take?
We're going back to this issue
of computational complexity,
but here, not of the problem
but of the solution.
So this is algorithmic
analysis.
We're analyzing the algorithm,
this exhaustive enumeration
algorithm, and trying to figure
out how long it's
likely to take to run.
Well, what does the running
time of this
algorithm depend upon?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It depends on
the actual square root.
Yes.
But in particular, the distance
of the actual square
root from the starting point.
So that's one factor
it depends on.
But that's not the
only factor.
What else does it depend on?
Oh, do we have an injury?
We had a dropped pass and
a deflection there.
All right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It depends on the
level of accuracy, so how you
define epsilon.
PROFESSOR: It depends upon
the value of epsilon.
Absolutely.
How long it takes to run.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Someone with
a concern for safety.
it depends upon the actual value
of epsilon, because if
epsilon is small, we may have
to take more steps to get a
precise enough answer.
And it depends upon
one more thing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
increment that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The increment.
Exactly.
Because the number of times we
go through the loop is going
to be related to how
big a step we
take each time through.
No applause?
Thank you.
So it depends upon all
of these things.
And here, since we're trying
to find a pretty [? big ?]
square root and a sort of
precise answer, but we're
taking tiny steps, it's
going to take a
long time to execute.
So we could make it faster.
For example, suppose I change
the step size to this.
Plus equal by says increment
the value by whatever the
right side is.
So I'm going to increment
it by 1.
Wow, it was really fast.
But it didn't work.
It failed.
That's not so good.
So I can't just do that.
And of course, it's not
surprising, because I ended up
jumping all over the answer.
I could make epsilon smaller,
but that seems like cheating.
So really, what I need to do is
find a better algorithm, a
better way to attack
the problem.
Fortunately, I don't
have to invent it.
Some people a lot smarter than
I am figured out a long time
ago a good method for solving
this kind of problem.
And they're doing it
using something
called bisection search.
As we look at this particular
implementation of it, we're
going to use two algorithmic
techniques that you'll use
over and over again because
they're generally useful.
So the first one related to
bisection search is we'll cut
the search space in half
each iteration.
So with my brute force
algorithm, we're trimming the
search base only a little
bit each step.
So if we think about it, what it
looks like, we had a space
of values to search
for the answer.
And I started here.
And each step, I just trimmed
off a tiny, tiny little bit,
0.001, leaving me a lot
of space to search.
And that's why it
took so long.
When I do bisection search, the
basic idea is each step I
want to cut the search
space in half.
Get rid of half of the search
space each time.
So one way I could do
it is I start with a
guess say in the middle.
Just pick some guess that's in
the middle of my search space.
And now I say is it too
high or too low?
I can easily answer
that question.
I square it.
See is my result bigger than
the actual square root or
smaller than the actual
square root?
That tells me whether my guess
is too big or too small.
Once I know that, I know which
side of the guess the right
answer is on.
So if I knew that my guess was
too big, then I know there's
no point in looking over
here for my next guess.
So I can get rid of this
whole half in one step.
Now, what should my
next guess be?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: My next
guess should be
half way through there.
Exactly.
And now, let's say this time
my answer is too small.
Then I know I can
get rid of this.
So now, I'm very quickly pruning
my search space.
If I think about that, how many
times am I likely to have
to prune it?
It's much faster, right?
As we'll see later, it's
basically log base 2.
If I have some number of
values to look at--
and by the way, how many values
do I have in my search
space to start with?
What determines it?
Clearly, the first value and the
last value, but also, how
small I'm dividing it up.
Right?
So I have to think
about that too.
What is the precision with
which I do this.
Am I looking at every
one millionth of a
number or every 0.01?
That will tell me
how big it is.
Once I know how big my search
space is, I know that if I
search it linearly looking at
every value, my worst cases, I
look at everything until
I get to the end.
Well, my best case is
I get lucky, and my
first guess is right.
But if I use bisection search,
my worst case is going to be
log number of values
in that space.
Because each time, I throw
half of them away.
We'll see that in more
detail later on.
Let's go back and look
at the code now.
So it starts as before with
a value for epsilon.
But now, I'm going to take a
lower bound, here, and an
upper bound on my
search space.
I'm going to say my initial
guess will be the upper bound
plus the lower bound
over 2 halfway
through my search space.
And then, I'm just going to work
my way through it until I
get to the answer or
don't find it.
So should we look at what's
going on here?
Let's try this.
Well, let's first make sure it
works for a small value.
Never test your program first
on something big.
Always try your program in
something small first.
Let's try it on that.
Got an answer.
Notice that it's different from
the answer we got last
time we looked for the
square root of 25.
But that's OK, because it's
still meets the specification.
It's still within epsilon of
the actual square root.
And I didn't have to say that
I wanted it below or the
square root or above, just
said within epsilon.
Sure enough, different
algorithm, different answer,
but equally good, but
a lot faster.
Now let's try it for
the big value.
Wow, that was a lot
faster, wasn't it?
It got me an answer.
Probably, not exactly
the same answer as
before but pretty close.
But it did it in only
26 guesses.
Pretty cool.
And in fact, we'll see over and
over again that bisection
search is a really good
technique for
finding quick answers.
And again, why is it 26?
Well, we had some number of
guesses to start with.
After 1, it was half as big,
then a quarter is big, and
eventually, log 2 of the size.
But what was the size?
Was it the number 12345?
No.
We already sort of talked
about that.
What was it?
Let's look at the code, and
let's think about what was the
size of our initial
search space.
It's a little bit tricky to
think about this, right?
Now, we have to think a little
bit harder about when we exit
the loop, because in
fundamentally, that's telling
me the size of the
search space.
So what determined the size
of the search space?
Well, we talked about the upper
and the lower bound.
But what's telling me
roughly speaking how
many divisions I have?
It's epsilon.
It's not 0.01 because when
I square it, it has to be
smaller than 0.01.
But that tells me roughly
how many I have.
And so it's going to be roughly
12345 divided by 0.01
squared, which turns out to
be 26.897 more or less.
So we could predict it.
And son of a gun, when we ran
it, we actually matched the
prediction.
That's the great thing about
algorithmic analysis.
We can actually get accurate
guesses as to how long a
program is likely
to take to run.
This is an important thing
because sometimes we do that
and we say, oh, it's going
to take a year.
I better not even try.
I better find a smarter
algorithm.
Or we do it and say, well, it's
going to take almost no
time at all.
I'm not going to waste
my time looking
for a smarter algorithm.
I'm going to live with
the one I've got.
It's important, and again, as
I said, it's a topic we're
going to get back to.
Of course, whether it's
26, 27, or even 50
doesn't really matter.
What matters is it's
not a billion.
Right?
Because we don't really care
small differences.
Whether it takes 25 or it
takes 50 will be an
imperceptible difference.
It's whether it's a huge
difference that matters.
And that's really the kind of
things we're going after is
orders of magnitude.
Now, I have a question
about this program.
I've been obsessing about
whether it's fast enough.
And we've shown it is.
But does it work?
Kind of more important.
It's always possible to write
a really fast program that
gives you the wrong answer.
The problem is to write a fast
program that give you the
right answer.
Does this program always work?
Well, it worked for 25.
It worked for 12345.
Is that good enough?
Probably not.
We might want to try it
in some other values.
I'll ask a simpler question.
Does it always work on
positive values?
All right.
I'll give you a hint.
No.
It does not.
I'm not going to, however,
tell you why it doesn't,
because I want you to
think about it.
And I want you to
tell me why it
doesn't in the next lecture.
But because I'm not a complete
sadist, I'll give you a hint.
When we use bisection search, or
for that matter, any search
method, we are depending upon
the fact that the answer lies
somewhere in the region
we're searching.
If indeed the answer is out
here or out here, then it
doesn't matter how carefully
I search this region.
I'm not going to find
the answer.
And so this program doesn't work
on some potential values
of x because the actual square
root of x will not lie in the
region that the program
is searching.
I leave it to you to think about
what such values are.
And we can talk about that
on the next lecture.
Suppose I want to use this
program to find the cube root.
Suppose it worked, and
I want it to use it
to find a cube root.
What would I have to change?
How would I change it, so it
found cube roots instead of
square roots?
Well, I can take it up.
I could use cut and paste, and
paste it into my editor and
get a new program.
And how would I change
that new program to
make it do cube roots?
Not very hard.
Think only two places
have to get changed.
That's for the simplicity,
say cube
roots of positive numbers.
I think you said the
right thing.
All I have to do is change that
two to a three and that
two to a three, and I'm done.
And I should probably change the
message to say cube root.
Pretty easy.
On the other hand, suppose I
also want it to find the
fourth root, and the fifth
root, and the sixth root,
however many roots.
Well, I'm going to get pretty
tired of cutting, and pasting,
and building a whole
bunch of things.
So really, what I want to do
is find a way to write the
code that will find the nth root
of a number for any n.
To do that, I'm going
to introduce a
new programming concept.
And that concept is
the function.
And that will be the main topic
of Thursday's lecture.